たくみ）おはよー
た）うぐるぅぅぅぅぅぅぅぅぅぅぅ
た）はじ、ぶぅｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒ
【たくみの激しい咳】
【たくみ撃退完了】
【たくみ運搬中】
はじめ）では、よろしくお願いします
美容師さん）はい、お願いします
は）こんにちは Dr. はじめだ
は）みなさん美容室、行きますか？
は）美容室って基本的にまあ月1回
は）少ない人で2か月3か月に
1回ぐらいの ペースで
は）美容室に行くと思う
は）だが 美容室というのは
は）もともと その髪の毛を
は）「あ、長くなってきたな」
と思った髪の毛を
は）切りに行って 理想の髪型になる
は）つまりどんな髪型でも
は）美容室に行けば理想の髪型に
は）近づけてくれる
は）ということは1回美容室に行くと
は）理想の髪型になるじゃないですか
は）その理想の髪型で
さらに美容室に行くと
は）さらなる理想の髪型に近づく
は）理想の髪型を理想の髪型に
近づけた髪型で
は）別の美容室に行って切ってもらうと
は）さらに理想の髪型を理想の髪型に
近づけた形を
は）理想の髪型に近づけた
理想の髪型になる
は）これを10回繰り返すと
は）人は完璧な理想な髪型に
近づくことが
は）できるのではないかと私は予想した
は）ていうことで今回は
は）僕のかわいいモルモットに
実験台になってもらった
は）彼には1日かけて美容室10か所に
通ってもらい
は）理想の髪型を追求し続けた結果
は）どのような髪型になるか
は）検証していこうと思う
は）ではいこう
は）坊主になんのかな
解説のはじめ）日頃から
「髪の毛切りたい」
解）「髪の毛切りたい」
と言っていたご様子
解）今回の実験で理想の髪型に
近づけるのでしょうか
解）おっと、最高の仕上がりです！
解）このままカットを終えたいところですが
解）あと9店舗あります
解）このあとどのように変化していくの
でしょうか、楽しみです
【たくみ運搬中】
解）2店舗目です、髪の毛の長さ的には
まだ切りやすいはず
解）すでに完成形であるこの髪型から
解）どのようなアレンジを
加えていくのでしょうか
解）おーっと！ここで衝撃の短さ！
解）2店舗目でまさかのこの短さ！
解）この先残り9店舗
解）嫌な未来が見えてきました
【たくみ運搬中】
解）3店舗目はTONI&GUYさん
解）オシャレな店ならではの
解）オシャレなショートヘアーに
仕上げてくれるのでしょうか
解）かっこいい髪型です！
解）サイドがかなり短くなっていい感じ
解）すっきりとしたこの髪型は
解）残念ながら保つことはできません
次に行きましょう！
解）4店舗目です
解）さあなかなかもう切る場所が
無いのでは？
解）この中でどのようなアレンジを
加えてくるのか
解）楽しみな局面ではあります
解）おーっと、まさかのカラーチェンジ！
解）黒髪からほのかな茶色に！
解）オシャレだが頭皮は痛そうだ！
解）オシャレに我慢はつきものとは
このことか！
【たくみ運搬中】
解）5店舗目です。
解）さあ色は変わったものの
長さは変わらずショート
解）ここからどのような変化が
見られるのでしょうか
解）おーっと！ここでパーマか！
解）わずかな生き残りの髪の毛に
パーマがかかっている！
美容師さん）いい感じにパーマかかってますんで
は）ありがとうございます
解）絶妙なオシャレ感が増したが
解）あと5回 美容室に行ってもらいまーす
【たくみ運搬中】
解）6店舗目です
解）もはや本人にも美容師さんにも
解）申し訳なくなってきましたが
解）止めるわけにはいきません
解）あと5店舗 頑張っていきましょう!
は）けっこう切る場所がないと思うんで
美容師さん）はい
は）なんとか可能であれば
美）はい
は）よろしくお願いします
美）いえいえ 分かりました
美）よろしくお願いします
は）ありがとうございます
【バリカンの音】
美）はい
解）おっと！オシャレだ！
解）剃り込みがオシャレだが
解）遠目で見ると？
解）あれ？
解）出川？
解）出川やー！
【たくみ運搬中】
解）はい7店舗目です
解）さあ剃り込みも入った
解）ここからどう変化する？
解）剃り込みが増えるパターンは
考えられますが
解）ここは美容師さんのセンスが
問われる！
解）剃り込みが無くなったー！
解）完全に出川になってしまいました！
解）横髪がほぼありません
解）もはや鼻毛の方が長い！
解）8店舗目です
解）サイドはもういじる余地なし
解）あとは前髪かトップぐらいですが
解）どうなるのか もう僕も知りません！
【美容師さん困惑】
【バリカンの音】
解）サイドの短い部分か
少し上がった！
解）出川ではなくサッカーの
解）中田英寿選手の雰囲気が
出てきましたが
解）本人はサッカーがとても下手です
解）練習しましょう
解）9店舗目です
解）もうここまできたら分かりません
解）あとはどうなるのでしょうか？
解）坊主にされるのも
解）時間の問題かもしれません…
美容師さん）じゃあこれで終わりますねー
解）短い！てっぺん以外はほぼ坊主です
解）さあ最後の店舗にバトンは渡された！
は）はい というわけで
は）ようやく9店舗が終わって
は）次がラストの10店舗目になります
は）これで理想に理想を重ねた上の
は）史上最強に男性の理想の髪型に
は）彼が近づくことができます
は）ちょっと見ていきましょう
は）ほぼないですww
は）はい というわけで最後の美容室で
は）彼はどのような髪型に
は）たどり着くのでしょうか
は）結果がとても楽しみです
は）では行こう
解）さあ最後の美容室です
解）あとはもうなるように
なるのでしょう
解）果たして待つのはモテヘアーか
解）それとも…
解）坊主か…
【バリカンの音】
た）あれ？
た）ここは？
た）どこ？
は）あっはっはっはっは
は）やあ
は）お目覚めのようだね
た）はじめ！？
は）ははっ
は）気付かれたか…
は）君は今
は）人間の理想の髪型だ
は）さあ アイマスクを取ってみるがよい
【ED】♬〜